okay what up guys welcome to the just
pearly things youtube channel welcome to
morning coffee thoughts even though
today it's a smoothie
um
today
i want to talk about
how i got to this point in my life
and how
i
ended up
here
um like running a youtube channel and
all that stuff so let me get water and
get water hold up so
i
a couple years ago i was a really big
drinker like not that long
trying to think i started drinking
when i went to college and then i drank
through college
and by my senior year
i was
heavy i mean i was like in really good
shape because i played a lot of sports
but
i don't know i just felt really
unhealthy and
i don't know
i just felt like
i was wasting a lot of my time
and so i wanted to quit drinking but i
felt like if i stayed in the same
environment like if i was around the
people that always drank
i was just gonna keep doing what i'd
been doing um and i was like i was 21
when i graduated college so
um i did a year of like a master's
program to play basketball and that was
when i started cutting back to like
maybe once a week
or once every other week or i forgot
what i did but i did it slowly over time
and then
the next year i took a job in milwaukee
and it's interesting because
i took that job
because
um
i i again i figured if i was around the
people that were always drinking i was
gonna keep drinking so
i moved to milwaukee i took a worse job
i had a better job offer in chicago but
i took the worst job because i wanted to
be in an environment where like i wasn't
tempted to drink
so
at that job in milwaukee
i
really thought long term about how i
wanted to like build my life and jordan
peterson helped me
with this thought process because he was
like talking about how you had to figure
out what you were interested in so i was
like okay what what do i want to do what
am i interested in i'm working a sales
job it was terrible don't ever sell
copiers don't do it it's not they might
sell it as a tech company it's not
you're selling copiers everyone hates it
so what i did was i
wrote down the things that i would do if
i was alone
so
there's a lot of things that i do in my
life not necessarily because like
i would do them but because they're kind
of fun to do as a family or as a group
so
i'll give you an example hiking
i
i i like hiking but i like hiking
because i like being around people
um
hiking probably isn't something
on a normal week that i would just do by
myself
and what i realized was when i organized
my interests there's three things i was
really interested in
media like political media um
music
and
sports those are the three things so
i just figured i could design my life in
a way that i was going to be able to do
all three of those things
so
um
what i did was i
i started learning youtube like i
started taking because i was only 22 and
the way that i was thinking was
i need to start this now because i'm
gonna i want the kids and i want to have
a family so if i start now
like like if it's now or never be like i
don't i just had this sense of like
urgency like if i don't do it now i'm
never gonna do it so i started learning
youtube and i started using my youtube
at my sales job and i kept doing that
until my job told me i needed to stop
doing that somewhat they fumbled a bag
honestly because
i probably would have stayed at that job
if they just moved me to the media and
like marketing department if they didn't
do that
so i quit um later that's a they told me
to stop doing the media stuff and i was
like i think i'm good at it so i quit
and i applied to play overseas
and then i
i started taking guitar lessons twice a
week because my thought was like if i do
this for five years
something's gonna hit and i i can just
keep building
and
i i watched a lot of youtubers and they
all said it takes between two to five
years to really like get good and be a
good youtuber so
my thought was
okay
um i just have to wait two three years
and just keep doing it every day
and that's what people quit or they
don't even start before they even like
go
but my point is this my point is this
um
if i didn't stop drinking none of this
[ __ ] would have happened
i was wasting so much time drinking in
college like
and i want to be clear it's not like i
never
i i'll i'll have a little bit a couple
times a year
right and i'm not i'm not even saying
i'm never gonna ever take a sip again
but like
re
drastically reducing the amount of times
in a week that you drank
is
like it makes your life so much better
and you see the people that continually
drink and continually make these poor
choices
and this is what happens they get fatter
and i know i talk about the whales a lot
but like it's just true you're not as
nice and happy of a person if you're fat
and even meat like i would be a lot
happier 10 pounds lighter
i'm working on it you wait you guys wait
one of these days i'm gonna hit it
and my thought
has always been even with my weight
right i really want to be
i mean i want 20 pounds lighter but i'm
just trying to get to 10 right now but
my thought is if i just keep trying and
keep trying like one day i'm going to
get it because i will fail at every diet
and i will fail it every exercise and i
will fail at everything until i freaking
get it and that was just my mentality
with youtube was like if i just keep
trying keep going like one day i'm going
to get it and it's going to be my
mentality of music that is the next
thing i'm going to do
you wait i'm going to drop an album it's
going to be fire
i'm i'm a good lyricist i'm good with my
words
and
like
and it's the same thing with
you know i want to get married i want to
find a husband and
my dad is a little bit
like he kind of looks at dating a little
differently than the red pill does
and he always would just tell me that
like dating is hard finding a husband or
a wife is like is a hard thing it's not
easy most people fail at it most people
can't do it
so you just have to keep trying
and
quitting but like my point is quitting
drinking and figuring out what i was
interested in early
changed my life because i've been able
to like build my life
in a way
that i can do the things that i love and
the other thing you have to think about
is
if you work hard because my thought is
like okay if i work hard at podcasting
for five years hopefully i can do that
the media i can do that the rest of my
life because
even
i want to have my family i want to raise
kids but like you used to do something
after that
like i mean kids are what
25 years which is a big chunk of your
life but i literally think about what
i'm gonna do when i'm old and i'm like
when i'm old old i'm trying to do music
like i'm gonna be that lady in the
nursing home just chilling on the piano
or you know wherever
so
i i got lucky and i have great parents
that always like push an entrepreneurial
like spirit in me
and just the idea that like
to keep trying because like something's
gonna hit and my dad always told me most
people aren't trying and i always ask my
dad okay when i was a kid i i'm telling
you guys i was so dumb and it's funny
because i get the comment that i'm smart
a lot
now like that's a very comment when
people are reacting to my videos
they'll always say
like that i'm smart
and
i'm not i'm not trying to i've just said
they said it okay i know the comment
section's always trying to humble me but
it's funny because i thought i was
stupid the first like 16 years of my
life because i was a year young in
school and honestly i'm just kind of
slow sometimes
and i was struggling in school and i
asked i said to my dad i said
dad um
like i'm so dumb i can't do this like i
was just you know complaining about
school my dad said um because my first
name is hannah a lot of people don't
know this he says hannah um
you
you aren't dumb and
it's not about how smart you are it's
about how hard you work and i said
that's easy for you to say dad you went
to the university of chicago you're so
smart my dad is very smart naturally
but he said you think about it like if
you put in an extra five hours a day
or whatever however many hours a day
from a young age and you do that every
single day for 20 30 years like you it
doesn't matter how smart you are you're
going to beat them
you're going to beat them
and
i i was like
yeah whatever that
that's another whatever
but the older i get the more like true i
see because that is because
the things that i like work on and work
at i just
tend to do well at and i don't think
it's necessarily because i'm smart but
it's because i make i make good choices
for the most part i'm not
i have i have my flaws i'm not gonna
someone in the comment section the other
day was like well why don't you tell us
all your flaws i'm like i don't have to
do that
i don't owe you a list
sorry i was just laughing he's like i
would take you on a date
but
like i forgot what the comment was but i
was like i'd be reading these comments
guys i read them
um
but
my point is the things that really
helped me in life and i know this is a
very disorganized coffee chat was
finding out what i liked early having a
good dad who pushed a hard like working
hard and i don't care what the man owes
fear says
i think that's a valuable trait even in
a woman because
you want him you want a mother that
works hard at being a mother
i'm not saying be like a working woman i
think the kids are always the first
priority but
i don't know i appreciated having a mom
and dad that worked hard and i that's a
core value of mine and again i i know
the man of sphere
says that that doesn't matter i'm sure
it doesn't to most men but i have
brothers and they absolutely have dumped
girls because they were lazy um
so we got
yeah interest working hard
and stopping drinking and partying at a
young age
um again i'm not saying
who knows like i'm not gonna get cocky
maybe maybe i'll fall victim back into
it i don't think so because my life is
just so much better now
and
but
i don't like quitting drinking the last
couple years has literally i i can play
guitar now i've done voice lessons for
two years i can sort of play piano um
i am
in a lot better shape than a lot of the
girls
that i grew up around
and
and i have this whole business that is
going great almost 100k subs
probably will be in the next like two
weeks hopefully we'll see hit that
button
i like
it's just crazy what happens when
you work hard at something you love and
that's the other thing my dad always
told me he always told me
to figure out what you like to do
because
then
you
you're gonna be able to put in more
hours into it and this my dad taught me
how to be a really long term thinker so
he always would say
figure out what you like because you're
gonna be able to put in so many more
hours than the people around you that
you're going to be good at it
and he always told me it's not about
money my dad loves making money and i
think that's what motivates him but he
always told me it's not about money it's
about being happy and it and he says
that he's talking about it in a
different way
than a lot of these girls talk about i
know
i say a lot on the channel like
marriage isn't about happiness and i
that's true
but
my dad
really always taught me that life is
like
about making good decisions working hard
and creating a life that makes you happy
so
morning coffee thoughts wisdom from my
father
um let me know what you all think in the
comments i'll talk to you guys next time
bye